i recently joined forces with the daily
wire in a new venture they call daily
wire plus
the plan is to build a multimedia empire
offering services on the philosophical
educational journalistic and
entertainment front including movies tv
shows and media for children and an
empire that will not fall prey to the
woke authoritarianism that has become
increasingly mandatory in so many places
including let's say the once great
disney why did i decide to do this and
what does daily wire plus offer first i
like working with ben shapiro and his
crew shapiro and i have some great plans
to undertake things together that we
could not do easily apart we're going to
run a seminar on exodus for example in
late july bringing together the smartest
and most articulate people we both know
to run through that book in an attempt
to enlighten ourselves and others and
prepare me to do another biblical series
in the same vein as the genesis
productions of 2017.
then we're going to israel to do
something similar there with the holy
sites of judaism christianity
and islam in april and may of next year
we're planning to tour eastern europe to
talk with political and cultural leaders
there particularly about the legacy of
communism and their well-grounded fears
of the resurgence of such ideas in the
west and that's
not all
second
i like the unabashedly shameless
capitalist ethos of the daily wire crew
they made me a great deal financially
one that offers me essentially unlimited
creative freedom and opportunity and
still means that i can use youtube as i
have been to offer free content to a
worldwide audience i've always deemed
myself an evil capitalist i run my own
businesses on a for-profit basis with
few exceptions learning through hard
experience that the discipline imposed
by the necessity of pleasing an audience
on an ongoing basis
is a plus not a minus
third i have been working in isolation
for a long time essentially since
departing from the university i've had a
very good team of people around me
but we can only do so much while
concentrating on producing high quality
educational and journalistic content and
having a professional crew of several
hundred people available to handle
logistics filming production travel
editing distribution marketing and
merchandising is a non-trivial advantage
fourth it was prudent to protect myself
and the intellectual property i have
produced and will continue to produce i
was just banned from twitter
synchronistically so to speak the same
day i partnered with the daily wire
youtube and i are getting along for now
although their lack of transparency on
the algorithm front is worrisome but god
only knows when i will say something
that the invisible powers that be
including some that are artificially
intelligent nature will decide that
they've heard enough from the
reprehensible magic super nazi there are
more reasons but that's a good start i
would like to also let everyone watching
and listening know
that i have poured over the details of
this arrangement for months
and thank you to my daughter michaela
and her husband jordan fuller for
attending so carefully to the details of
this and that we are thrilled with the
outcome and ready to go forward
no holds barred to subscribe
go to
dailywireplus.com
you will have immediate access to the
new projects that we have posted
including a new mini series dragons
monsters and men that i recorded as the
kickoff for the dw plus project daily
wire plus has 890 000 subscribers
netflix has 200 million dw plus
is not woke
is netflix
decide that for yourself but give some
consideration to supporting this new
joint venture and help us continue
educating and informing and battling on
the side of tradition in the raging
culture war go if you would
to dailywireplus.com
to subscribe that's dailywireplus.com
and if you haven't yet done so and you
feel like doing it hit the subscribe
button on my youtube channel thanks very
much all of you
you